JEFFREY EISENACH: Well, welcome everyone.
My name is Jeff Eisenach, and I’m a visiting
scholar here at the American Enterprise Institute.
It’s a wonderful pleasure for us today to
welcome FCC Chairman Ajit Pai to the American
Enterprise Institute.
Over the course — well, I’ve known Ajit
for some years, but over the course of the
past several months, I’ve had the opportunity
to get to know him better in my role as part
of the Trump transition team for the Federal
Communications Commission.
And when people ask me about that, I tell
them that of all of the various transition
teams for the Trump transition, I had the
lightest lift of all, and that’s because
we had these two wonderful Republican commissioners
present and in place at the FCC.
And people would ask me, “What would the
Trump administration’s communications policy
agenda be after the inauguration?”
And I said, “Well, don’t ask me.
Go to the FCC website, and read the dissents
of Ajit Pai and Mike O’Rielly over the course
of the past few years, and you’ll see it
spelled out with tremendous substance and
detail.”
I want to talk for just a second about Ajit’s
accomplishments over the past 102 days.
Obviously, there’s some controversial issues
in front of the commission, but there are
some issues in front of the commission which
ought to be — at least ought to be less
controversial, and Ajit has taken those on
at a pace and with a level of substance and
success far more akin to an internet startup
than a typical Washington moribund bureaucracy.
First of all, Ajit has put in place commonsense
procedural reforms like making notices, orders
public before they’re voted on by the commission.
What a concept.
You thought that could have happened before.
Revoking the staff’s editorial privileges
so after the commission votes on something,
the staff now actually has to carry out what
the commission voted on instead of rewriting
it under historical editorial privileges.
And many of these are bipartisan, including
another one being simply telling the staff
that when a commissioner, even a commissioner
from the other political party, asks you for
information about a proceeding or something
going on at the commission, you should answer
the question.
Now, you would think that’s all just good
government, but it is the antithesis of the
previous four years under the previous chairman,
who we won’t name here.
Chairman Pai has also taken a weed-whacker
to the regulatory underbrush, little-noticed
changes — eliminating unnecessary paperwork
requirements and, at the other end of the
spectrum, actually requiring that companies
applying for government subsidies demonstrate
their bona fides to receive those subsidies
and spend them in a responsible way.
What another concept.
On the substantive front, it’s been change
after change after change, all of them in
the spirit of another FCC chairman, 17 years
ago, Chairman Bill Kennard who spoke eloquently
about the need to create an FCC for the 21st
century, to clean out the regulatory underbrush,
to move from a system of siloes and heavy-handed
ex ante regulation to a competition-based
framework, an enforcement-based framework
of ex-post regulation consistent with the
increasing competitiveness of the telecommunications
marketplace.
And on issue after issue, Chairman Pai has
moved that agenda along, including the very
visible issues, which I’m sure we’ll get
into today, but also less visible issues,
something as important as beginning the process
of deregulating the marketplace for business
data services, which is essentially the internet
backbone services and, which is and has been
competitive — we’re finally going to get
around to deregulating that.
And something as you might think mundane or
technical as beginning the process of permitting
LTE-U into the marketplace, allowing new technologies
to be rolled out without the heavy hand of
government slowing innovation.
So I’ve talked long enough.
I’m not going to give a long introduction
of Ajit.
He is currently chairman of the Federal Communications
Commission.
Previously, he was a member of the Federal
Communications Commission.
Prior to that, he served in the General Counsel’s
Office at the Federal Communications Commission.
His dedication to the agency I think is an
important part of his success.
And it’s worth, I think, going back and
looking at his first speech as chairman, which
was to the staff of the agency, reassuring
them that his purpose is to advance the agency
and its professional staff, not to attack
it.
And I think that’s been another component
of his chairmanship that’s been so important.
Lest we forget, Ajit graduated from Harvard
University.
He received his law degree from the University
of Chicago, where he was editor of the law
review, and so we are dealing not only with
a great leader but a tremendous intellect.
Ajit Pai, thank you for being here.
(Applause.)
AJIT PAI: Thank you, Jeff, for those very
kind words.
Thanks to the entire team at AEI for putting
this event together.
Jeff, I especially appreciate the comparison
to former Chairman Bill Kennard, distinguished
public servant and someone I can now call
a friend.
To be mentioned even in the same sentence
as Chairman Kennard is a high honor indeed.
It is great to be back here at the American
Enterprise Institute.
Being here today reminds me that 2016 was
a time of great change in Washington.
Looking back, it’s clear that we witnessed
a momentous event, one that I’m sure caused
many people some consternation, brought tremendous
joy to others, and required a lot of people
to pack up their offices and move out.
I’m referring, of course, to AEI’s decision
to move into this wonderful new space after
many years on 17th Street.
Congratulations on the move.
But in all seriousness, AEI and its scholars
have done tremendous work by making the case
for expanding freedom, for extending individual
opportunity, and for strengthening America’s
free enterprise system.
And in particular, AEI has shown thought leadership
on communications policy.
And much of the credit for that goes to Jeffrey
Eisenach, who has really done so much work
over the years, including during the transition
that he mentioned.
So, thank you, Jeff, for your scholarship,
for your friendship, and for your counsel.
Now, earlier this week, as Jeff pointed out,
we reached the 100-day mark of my tenure as
chairman.
It sure doesn’t feel like 100 days, I have
to tell you.
Time flies much more quickly in this job than
it did when I was in the minority.
But, by any objective measure, we’ve hit
the ground running, and we have had a very
productive three-plus months at the FCC.
Here’s just one data point for your consideration.
In my first 100 days, the FCC adopted 49 items.
To put that number in perspective, during
the prior two permanent chairmen’s first
100 days, the commission adopted 25 and 34
items.
I know what you’re thinking.
You know, as legendary UCLA basketball coach
John Wooden once said, never mistake activity
for achievement.
So I thought it would be helpful this morning
to highlight some of the actions we’ve taken
and to explain how they fit into a broader
strategic vision.
And that vision includes five goals that are
important to me and, hopefully, to you.
Number one, closing the digital divide.
Number two, modernizing our rules.
Number three, promoting innovation.
Number four, protecting consumers and public
safety.
And number five, improving the agency’s
operations.
Now, these are the goals that I’ve emphasized
since I arrived at the FCC almost exactly
five years ago today.
These are the goals that have shaped and animated
my first 100 days as chairman, and these are
the goals that I hope will be the agency’s
beacon in the years to come.
So let’s start with closing the digital
divide.
On my first full day as chairman, as Jeff
pointed out, I delivered remarks to the agency’s
fantastic and talented staff.
And I focused on one issue: bringing the benefits
of the digital age to all Americans.
And this principle goes back to the commission’s
founding statute.
Section One of the Communications Act of 1934
charged the FCC with making communications
services available, so far as possible, to
all the people of the United States.
And to me at least, this mission is more vital
than ever.
After all, broadband opens doors to opportunity
in almost every aspect of modern American
life, whether it’s looking for a job, getting
medical care, doing your homework, keeping
in touch with friends and family, or engaging
with your favorite regulators.
That was a joke actually.
I’m here all week.
Broadband has also given rise to what I’ve
called the democratization of entrepreneurship.
With a powerful plan and a digital connection,
you can raise capital, you can start a business,
you can hire people, and you could reach a
global customer base from anywhere in America.
And so I believe that every American who wants
to participate in our digital economy should
be able to do so.
Access to digital opportunity should not depend
on who you are, where you live, what you look
like, or where you’re from.
But, to be clear, we’re not where we need
to be.
If you live in rural America, you are much
less likely to have high-speed internet access
than if you live in a city.
If you live in a low-income neighborhood,
you are much less likely to have high-speed
internet access than if you live in a wealthier
area.
The digital divide in our country is real,
and it is persistent.
It makes it harder for many of our fellow
American citizens to improve their lives,
and it takes a significant toll on America’s
economy and our global competitiveness.
When I became chairman, the FCC needed to
step up its efforts to close this gap.
And that is exactly what we’ve done.
My first two meetings as FCC Chairman involved
conversations with consumer advocates and
small broadband providers on ways to promote
digital empowerment.
My very first vote as chairman was to partner
with the state of New York to deliver $170
million for broadband deployment in upstate
areas where residents have been bypassed for
far too long.
And the first commission meeting for which
I had the power to set the agenda featured
two significant measures to expand broadband
access in unserved areas.
One was an order, passed unanimously, to bring
mobile broadband to millions of Americans
through what is known as the Mobility Fund
Phase Two.
Previously, the FCC was spending about $25
million a month of taxpayer money to subsidize
wireless carriers in areas where private capital
was already doing the job.
We are redirecting that spending and more
— $4.53 billion over the next decade — in
order to bring 4G LTE service to rural Americans
who don’t have it today.
And we’re doing it in an efficient, fiscally
responsible way by using a competitive reverse
auction to allocate those funds.
Now, at the same meeting we decided — again,
on a bipartisan basis — to move forward
with $2 billion in wired broadband investment
through what’s called Phase Two of our Connect
America Fund.
Here too, we set up a competitive bidding
process to get the most bang for the buck
in terms of bringing high-speed internet access
to currently unserved rural Americans.
Our rules for this auction will encourage
a wide range of entities to compete and to
participate, from wireless internet service
providers to electric utilities.
Now, these two capital investment plans will
bring internet access to many unserved Americans.
And they will put many Americans to work,
building next-generation networks in rural
America.
But these were just parts of the opening act.
Our most recent FCC meeting included three
initiatives designed to make it easier for
companies to build and expand high-speed broadband
networks.
We launched, again unanimously, a proceeding
to lower costs and speed the deployment of
new wireline infrastructure, to speed the
transition from copper networks to modern
fiber networks.
This means that more money will be spent on
the resilient technologies of tomorrow, not
the fading networks of yesterday.
And we launched, yet again unanimously, a
proceeding to facilitate the deployment of
the hundreds of thousands of small cells that
will power the 5G networks of tomorrow.
And we eliminated, still yet again unanimously,
a rule that needlessly penalized rural carriers,
telephone companies for deploying broadband
to certain parts of their communities.
Looking ahead, we also want to explore fresh
ideas for tackling the long-standing challenge
of this digital divide.
And to that end, we created the Broadband
Deployment Advisory Committee, a panel of
experts to make recommendations to the FCC
about strategies to promote better and faster
and cheaper broadband.
Over 380 individuals applied to serve on this
committee, representing community groups,
community organizations and consumer organizations,
government, and industry — a diverse and
highly impressive pool of applicants.
We recently invited 29 individuals to serve
on this committee, led by the highly talented
Elizabeth Pierce, the CEO of Quintillion Networks,
and Kelleigh Cole of the Utah Broadband Outreach
Center.
The BDAC, as we call it, held its first meeting
last month, and I expect it will make a major
difference in our work to connect all Americans.
Some of the actions we’ve taken to spur
broadband deployment and to close the digital
divide dovetail with our second major priority,
which is modernizing the commission’s rules
and eliminating unnecessary regulatory burdens.
You often hear talk about how regulatory red
tape imposes real costs and stifles investment
and innovation.
Here’s one statistic that gives you a sense
of how real and how significant those costs
are.
According to the Office of Management and
Budget, the FCC imposes $800 million each
and every year in paperwork burdens.
That’s right: $800 million each year.
This doesn’t count the money that people
must spend paying workers to fill out all
of this paperwork.
And, again, these are only the FCC’s paperwork
burdens that I’m talking about.
The total regulatory burden that the FCC places
on the private sector is actually much higher
than that.
To me at least, the fundamental question is
this: Do we want that money to be diverted
to lawyers and accountants figuring out how
to comply with FCC’s regulator requirements,
or do we want it to be spent delivering American
consumers better and faster and cheaper internet
access?
No offense to my friends in the communications
bar, but to me at least, the answer to that
question is pretty clear.
Now, paperwork aside, we are reviewing the
FCC’s rules across the board and deciding
which ones still make sense in the digital
age.
As part of this review, we’re asking whether
the costs of a rule outweigh the benefits.
When the facts warrant, we will not hesitate
to revise overly burdensome rules or to repeal
them altogether.
You don’t need a weatherman to know that
the wind is blowing certain FCC rules toward
modification or elimination.
And that’s especially true, by the way,
for small businesses.
Federal regulations have a disproportionate
effect on these companies.
And these companies, remember, are often the
linchpin to a more competitive marketplace,
and they don’t have the compliance resources
to withstand a regulatory onslaught.
I’m very sensitive to the impact that our
regulations can have on such businesses.
And that’s why, in my first week as chairman,
I proposed to relieve small internet service
providers from costly and overly burdensome
reporting requirements associated with the
Title Two order, and we did that in February.
This is just one example of many that illustrate
how we are modernizing our rules.
We also relaxed unnecessary command-and-control
regulations for business data services to
create greater incentives for the private
sector to invest in next-generation networks.
We streamlined various accounting requirements
for many wireline carriers, requirements that
literally required them to maintain two different
sets of books.
We eased reporting burdens for volunteer board
members of noncommercial broadcasters.
We updated our interpretation of our equal
employment opportunity rules to account for
the ways that people actually look for jobs
today.
And we eliminated two filing requirements:
broadcasters’ public correspondence files
and cable operators’ principal headend locations
that no longer made any sense.
Now, I recognize that as I go through this
litany, these decisions and others like them
might seem like small potatoes.
But remember what former Senate Minority Leader
Everett Dirksen once had to say about spending:
a billion here, a billion there, and pretty
soon you are talking real money.
So, too, as we go about eliminating a rule
here and a rule there, we will end up substantially
adjusting our rules to match the realities
of the modern marketplace, and that is something
that is good for consumers and good for companies
alike.
A third key FCC priority I mentioned is promoting
innovation across the communications industry.
I might be new to the chairmanship, but I’ve
served on the commission, as I said, for almost
half a decade.
During that time, I have had the great privilege
of traveling all across this country and to
all corners of the land.
And I can report firsthand that the entrepreneurial
spirit is alive and well in America.
Just this March, I took my first road trip
as chairman, visiting Pittsburgh and Youngstown
and Cleveland and Detroit.
Along the way, I met with an incredible array
of startups: a mobile app company that is
already helping 80 million people around the
world learn new languages for free, a virtual
reality gaming entrepreneur, a new online
platform to provide treatment for people with
addiction, and many, many more like them.
I also visited established entities like the
Cleveland Clinic, where I witnessed a demonstration
of a mobile stroke unit that is using new
technology to cut the time needed to assess
and stabilize a stroke patient by an average
of 38 minutes, critical minutes when you consider
that the brain for a stroke patient loses
two million brain cells every single minute.
Whether it’s someone tinkering in a small-town
garage or a growing company in a major technology
hub, we at the FCC want to help American entrepreneurs
bring these big ideas to life.
And that’s why we’ve put in place a process
to implement, at long last, Section Seven
of the Communications Act, a long-neglected
law.
Going forward, if an innovator or an inventor
files a petition or application at the FCC
for the approval of a new technology or service,
we will abide by the law, and we will make
a decision within one year.
There will be no more waiting indefinitely
for an answer.
As the old saying goes, tell me yes, tell
me no, or just tell me something.
Now, that’s why we’ve changed our experimental
licensing program and we’ve launched a new
website to make it easier for parties to register
proposed new experiments.
This new type of experimental license will
allow greater flexibility for parties, including
universities and research labs and health
care facilities and manufacturers of radio
frequency equipment, to develop their technologies
and services while protecting incumbent services
against harmful interference.
That’s why, as Jeff pointed out, we authorized
the first-ever LTE-unlicensed devices in the
five gigahertz band, a significant advance
for wireless innovation and spectrum sharing.
This gives wireless consumers the best of
both worlds: more robust and seamless networks
when their phones are relying on cellular
networks and the continued enjoyment of Wi-Fi.
And that’s why we began the process of allowing
television broadcasters to fully enter the
digital age by using the next-generation television
standard on a voluntary, market-driven basis.
This new transmission standard, known as ATSC
3.0, is the first one to marry the advantages
of broadcasting and the internet.
And it could let broadcasters offer much better
services in various ways, 4K transmissions,
immersive audio, better accessibility options,
and much, much more.
Now, one more point about our approach to
promoting innovation.
We want to encourage innovation throughout
the internet economy.
That means innovation not just at the edge
of the networks, but also innovation at the
core of those networks, within the networks
themselves.
Also, we want to encourage business-model
innovation and more options for consumers.
That’s a big reason why we closed the FCC’s
investigation into free-data offerings.
Wireless companies offering consumers something
for free has, shockingly, proven popular among
consumers, especially low-income Americans.
And it’s also made the wireless marketplace
more competitive than ever.
Going forward, the FCC will seek to promote,
not to prevent, that kind of innovation.
And that leads to our fourth guiding priority,
which is protecting consumers, and that goes
hand-in-hand with promoting public safety.
The most effective tool for protecting consumers
is a competitive marketplace.
But as we’ve seen, competition sometimes
isn’t enough to guard consumers against
scams and other unsavory practices.
When consumers feel they are being taking
advantage of, they often turn to the FCC for
help.
And this FCC is taking action.
The most number-one source of consumer complaints
at the FCC for many years has been robocalls.
We’ve all experienced them during our daily
lives.
And here, the agency has moved aggressively
to save Americans from the scourge of Rachel
from cardholder services and many of her friends.
We have sought to give providers more leeway
to block calls that used a spoofed caller
ID number and that seemed to be from an unassigned
or invalid phone number.
This would impede the illegitimate callers
and scam artists who often engage in call
spoofing and prey upon some of our most vulnerable
populations.
We have also taken action to protect consumers,
many of whom are small businesses, from scams.
For instance, we levied a $1 million fine
against a Florida-based long-distance carrier
for impersonating representatives of customers’
existing long-distance providers and illegally
switching the customers’ long-distance carriers.
Another area where this FCC has made a mark
is in ensuring that communications services
are accessible to Americans with disabilities.
For instance, we’ve already taken steps
to improve the quality and the efficiency
of video relay services.
These are services that help people who are
deaf, hard-of-hearing, or speech disabled
communicate.
Our reforms will encourage more competition,
and they will help make these services more
useful and meaningful to disabled Americans
in their daily lives.
Public safety is another dimension of consumer
protection.
Again, this is a principle that is rooted
in our founding statute, which charges the
FCC with protecting the safety of life and
property through communications.
One area in which we delivered results involves
the problem of contraband cell phones.
These devices are being smuggled into prisons
and jails across the country.
I’ve seen it for myself in minimum security
facilities in Massachusetts, to maximum security
facilities in Georgia.
Now, these devices are smuggled into prisons
and jails to be used for hits on witnesses,
scams on innocent consumers, and many other
illicit purposes, all of which impact guards
and inmates and all of us ultimately.
I’m proud to say that here, the FCC unanimously
adopted reforms that will enable correctional
facilities to detect and to block the use
of these contraband cell phones.
We’re also looking at other technological
solutions going forward.
Outside of the rulemaking process, we also
rushed to the aid of Jewish Community Centers
and law enforcement to help combat a wave
of bomb threats earlier this year.
And when a major 911 outage hit a couple of
months ago, we immediately launched an investigation
to figure out what had happened and what could
be done to prevent it from happening again.
Now, the last priority that I would like to
highlight is enhancing transparency and improving
the way the agency does business.
Long before I became chairman, I said that
good process drives good policy.
As you may have heard back then, I had some
problems with FCC processes.
One of my favorite targets was the practice
of preventing the public from seeing a proposal
or order until after the FCC voted on it.
I was told for many years it was unlawful
to change course or unwise to do so.
But having spent almost five years talking
about ways we could do things better, I was
eager to begin doing things differently, and
we did.
In the category of they said it couldn’t
be done, we started making the text of items
available to the public on the internet three
weeks in advance of commission meetings.
Of all the things that we’ve done over our
first 100 days, that is one of the initiatives
that I’ve heard the most positive feedback
about.
Indeed, now that we let the sunlight in, it’s
hard to remember why this was even a controversial
proposal in the first place.
And to me at least, this is a useful reminder
of two things.
Number one, never underestimate the power
of government inertia.
Number two, the most common defense for a
long-standing practice is “That’s just
the way we’ve always done it.”
It might be a signal to think outside the
box and to begin doing things differently.
Speaking of doing things differently, I have
long been concerned that the economists at
the agency haven not been systematically incorporated
into the FCC’s policy work.
Instead, their expertise is typically applied
in an ad hoc fashion and often late into the
process.
Moreover, the economists are sprinkled among
the agency’s many bureaus and offices.
We are taking a major step toward correcting
that.
A month ago, I kick-started a process to establish
an Office of Economics and Data.
This office will combine economists and data
professionals from around the FCC.
And I envision it providing economic analysis
for rulemakings, transactions, and auctions;
managing the commission’s data resources;
and conducting longer-term research — those
famed white papers, for instance — on ways
to improve the commission’s long-term policies.
Now, my goal is to have the new office up
and running by the end of the year.
And I’d be remiss if I didn’t acknowledge
the prior work done by Jeff Eisenach, by Ross
Layton, Mark Jamison, and many others for
providing the intellectual foundation for
creating this office.
So there you have it: a recap of our first
100 days.
Obviously, this is not an exhaustive list.
For example, I mentioned neither the FCC’s
incentive auction, nor my infamous Reese’s
peanut butter mug.
But I hope I’ve illustrated at least in
brief how we intend to meet the core priorities
of this agency: closing the digital divide,
modernizing our rules, promoting innovation,
protecting consumers and public safety, and
improving the agency’s operations.
Now, it’s also important to note that our
accomplishments over the first 100 days were
truly a team effort.
Commissioners Mignon Clyburn and Mike O’Rielly
have been critical partners in the commission’s
work.
For example, when it comes to closing the
digital divide, Commissioner Clyburn has played
a vital role and has offered many productive
suggestions.
Commissioner O’Rielly has been a leader
when it comes to process reform and to easing
unnecessary regulatory burdens.
And I could have no better partner than him.
So I would like to take this opportunity to
publicly thank each of them for the work they
have done over the past several months.
And in those rare instances when we have disagreed,
the exchange of our views has made for a better
ultimate work product.
And of course, I must thank the unsung heroes
of the FCC, our amazing staff.
None of what we have accomplished so far would
have been possible without their efforts.
I am well aware that many of them have worked
very long hours over the last 100 days, often
under very tight deadlines, but their work
has been stellar, their demeanor has been
professional, and their dedication to the
cause has been unflagging.
And so I appreciate all of the sacrifices
that they have made in order to advance the
public interest.
Now, as for me, I’m of course pleased that
we’ve gotten off to a fast start.
But I would stress that that’s all it is:
just a start.
A good beginning, of course, is no guarantee
of ultimate success.
If you don’t believe me, ask the 2017 Atlanta
Falcons, the 2016 Golden State Warriors, the
1986 Red Sox, and many other teams.
So there’s a lot more to do in these fields.
And I’m looking forward to doing it, to
building a brighter digital future for all
Americans.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thanks again to AEI for hosting us.
And I look forward to continuing to work with
you in the years to come.
(Applause.)
MR.
EISENACH: So we’re going to engage in a
conversation here for just a couple of minutes,
and then we’ll turn the floor open to questions.
So one topic you didn’t talk about on your
speech I’ll go ahead and raise just so it
doesn’t go unmentioned.
I bet we get a question or two about it also,
and that is the Open Internet proceeding.
MR.
PAI: I’m not familiar with that.
Is that a big deal?
(Laughs.)
MR.
EISENACH: I’ve read something about that
recently.
So, you know, without kind of getting deep
into the substance of the thing again, you
know, you’ve written about that at length,
and you know, I think the arguments are well
understood.
But maybe looking ahead at the process, first
of all, the process at the FCC, the last time
this issue came around was criticized.
So maybe speak a little bit about the process
as you see it and the process reforms and
how they play into the FCC’s deliberations.
But then also, how do you see the role of
Congress, how do you see the role of the courts
in resolving, you know, what’s obviously
a contentious issue?
MR.
PAI: A great question.
So, first and foremost, we want to make sure
that this is a proceeding that respects the
Administrative Procedure Act and sort of basic
principles of good government.
And that’s why it was really important to
me that the pilot project that I announced
in my second week in office extended to all
of the proposals that we would be considering,
including this one.
And so that’s why, after I made a speech
where I outlined my proposal to reform our
internet regulations, I wanted to put it up
on the internet immediately.
And, as I said at the time, you may disagree
with what I proposed, you may agree with it.
But at least you’ll be able to see exactly
what it was that I was thinking and why.
And that’s really important to me because
I don’t claim to have a monopoly on wisdom.
I think it’s important for the public to
feel like they have a seat at the table.
And for the FCC to simply say, “This is
our plan, just trust us, this is what’s
in it” is not good enough for me as what
happened in the last iteration.
And so going forward, we’re going to have
a very open and transparent process following
on May 18 of the notice of proposed rulemaking
is adopted.
We will have approximately three months for
public comments.
We already had several weeks of that.
And I think until August 16 is the time for
the public to have its say.
And, at that point, the FCC’s staff, which
is dedicated, as I pointed out, they’ll
take stock of the facts in the record, and
then we at the appropriate time will make
the judgments based on those facts and the
law as we interpret it.
Now, speaking of the law, you asked about
the courts.
And here too I think we’re guided of course
by the decisions that the courts have made.
And so I think it’s important to remember,
number one, that the Supreme Court in 2005
explicitly blessed the path that we have proposed
to take.
In fact, just earlier this week, when the
DC Circuit rejected the en banc petition for
review, they explicitly said, you can see
at the bottom of page four the court’s opinion,
where Judges Srinivasan and Tatel recognized
that the Brand X decision stands for the proposition
that the agency has discretion about how to
classify internet access.
And so going forward, we of course want to
be guided by these legal principles, and that’s
something that’s very important to us.
You also mentioned Congress.
Congress, of course, has very great interest
in these issues, and that’s why I’ve been
doing outreach to members of Congress on both
sides of the aisle and to both Houses of Capitol
Hill to make sure that I make myself as accessible
as I can be.
And people might end up disagreeing.
Of course, this is a topic that I recognize
is highly fraught in political differences
and policy differences.
But, at the end of the day, I think that a
lot of the rhetoric obscures the basic point
that I’ve been trying to make, which is
that the Clinton administration got it right
in the 1990s, at the dawn of the internet
age.
This is not a radical position that I’ve
been trotting out.
This was the reality from the dawn of the
commercial internet until 2015.
I mean, if you go back and look at President
Clinton’s statement, the internet should
develop unfettered from federal and state
regulation.
Go back and look at my predecessor, Chairman
Kennard’s statements, that he at the crossroads
of the internet, at the beginning, he didn’t
want to dump, as he put it, the morass of
Title Two on the internet type.
Take a look at the bipartisan statements that
we saw from many senators, including Senators
Wyden and former Senator Kerry, where they
urged the FCC not to reclassify this new technology
as a Title Two service.
There’s a reason why they did that.
It’s because they saw the potential of this
new technology, and they didn’t want to
import the legacy rules from the Ma Bell monopoly
years into this new and evolving service.
And so all I’m simply saying going forward
is that — you know, I recognize that, you
know, some people would prefer government
micromanagement of everything internet.
Some people would prefer it to be the Wild
West, no regulation at all.
My pitch is pretty simply.
We go down this middle path of light-touch,
Clinton-era regulation.
It’s proved to work.
It’s given us $1.5 trillion in infrastructure
investment.
The internet economy is the envy of the world.
It’s the very re ason that some of you at
this very moment are able to tweet out your
vigorous disagreement with whatever I just
said.
It’s one of the great platforms I think
for democratization and entrepreneurship and
engagement.
Let’s just keep that going going forward.
MR.
EISENACH: Thank you for that.
And speaking of Chairman Kennard and the Clinton
administration, Chairman Kennard’s strategic
plan from 1999 talked about the growth of
competition.
He said, you know, our ability to move down
the path of a less regulatory approach depends
ultimately on some things occurring in terms
of — he talked specifically about whether
DSL would ever — you know, how that technology
would develop.
He talked — you know, looking forward, he
talked about I wonder how cable modem technology
will ever develop and will that be really
a good way to get to the internet.
Another part of that competitive milieu is
the question of wireless and wireline competition.
So yesterday, if I think I got this right,
the CDC reported that, for the first time
there are more mobile-only telephone consumers
in households in the United States than there
are wired households in the United States.
So my question is — I don’t think — if
this is in some particular proceeding or something
you can’t answer, I understand.
But just as in general, would you think at
this point that wireless is a competitor,
a substitute for wireline and the FCC might
— is the Phoenix decision still law?
MR.
PAI: It’s a great question.
I mean, to me at least, they are very competitive
offerings.
If you look at how consumers are using their
mobile devices, the phone call is one of the
last things that people typically think about
now when they pick up a phone.
And that’s a remarkable transformation.
I mean, for those of us of a certain age at
least, I still remember those big, you know,
phones that were hard to hold, and you’d
make a voice call and the quality was scratchy.
I thought, “How is this device ever going
to become an integral part of life?”
But starting with the iPhone introduction
in 2007, all the way until 2017, it’s incredible
to see how we use these devices.
And, you know, I look at the apps that I use
every single day.
It’s amazing.
From fast food to Twitter to checking my email
to, you know, reserving a flight, our iPhones
are some of these platforms for innovation.
And so the internet is a critical part of
that, and especially as 4G LDE gets rolled
out, it’s 5G networks with gigabit three
port or even more become possible, as the
next generation of Wi-Fi comes onboard so
we’re able to — for instance, free five
gigahertz spectrum or even 50 and 70 gigahertz
spectrum for wireless innovation.
I think we’re increasingly going to see
that wireless is not just this imperfect substitute
for wired connections.
It is going to be the dominant means by which
people access the internet, the preferable
means.
And so I think the FCC needs to take stock
of that and make the appropriate policy decisions
as a result.
MR.
EISENACH: I agree.
The reference — this just occurred to me
earlier today, and I haven’t looked it up.
The Phoenix decision was Cox applied for deregulation
in the Phoenix marketplace, I must say.
And this was not that many years ago.
And the commission’s decision was based
on the conclusion — to deny the request
— was based on the conclusion that wireless
voice cell phones were not a substitute.
And as far as I know, that’s still law.
MR.
PAI: Yeah.
EISENACH: Isn’t it?
So maybe I’m speaking about the regulatory
underbrush.
MR.
PAI: I believe it is, yeah.
EISENACH: Maybe we could concede those.
MR.
PAI: Well, certainly it’s also important
to note that for the purposes of the Title
Two order, I mean, the FCC had no problem
lumping wireless in with wire networks, and
so, I mean, under the well-established case
of goose versus gander, I think it’s important
to be consistent here and to take a holistic
view of the marketplace that’s —
MR.
EISENACH: I decided convergence had taken
a major step when Microsoft stopped calling
this stuff on my Windows 10 operating system
programs and started calling them apps.
We’ve converged.
So another thing that you’ve been active
with over the course of the past 102 days
is collaborating in a number of ways with
our mutual friend, Maureen Ohlhausen, at the
Federal Trade Commission.
So talk a little bit about the FTC-FCC collaboration
and how you see that playing out over time.
MR.
PAI: Chairman Ohlhausen has been a terrific
partner not just over the last 102 days, but
over the last several years.
And I’ve really enjoyed the chance to work
with her on some of the issues that have raised
a lot of public attention.
For example, privacy — she and I have consistently
said that we share the same goal here.
And the goal is a consistent and comprehensive
framework that protects consumers whenever
they go online.
And so I have really been grateful not just
to call her a friend but also to rely on her
as a resource to let us know what the FTC’s
capabilities are, what the scope of its legal
authorities are, and what the best way to
secure consumer protection in the digital
age is.
And so going forward that’s certainly going
to be the case.
I know that my staff and hers have collaborated
closely as well.
And I’m really excited about the chance
to deliver more results of that sort.
MR.
EISENACH: Does the FCC chairman support the
end of the common carrier exemption at the
Federal Trade Commission?
MR.
PAI: I think our time is coming to a close.
I’m just kidding.
I can’t take an official position on this.
It’s a decision for Congress to make obviously
in consultation with the Federal Trade Commission,
but that’s one of the areas that I know
Chairwoman Ohlhausen and even Commissioner
McSweeney I believe have called for congressional
attention.
MR.
EISENACH: I was at the FTC in the 1980s when
we were pushing for ending the common carrier
exemption.
So the FTC would like that.
I want to stop there.
We’ve got about 15 minutes left, and we
promised to have time for questions from the
audience.
So I’ll stop my questions there, and the
floor is open.
We have microphones with staff on the sides.
And so raise your hand.
Identify yourself.
We’ll take the first one here.
And wait for
the microphone to come to you.
Q: Thank you.
Thank you, Chairman.
Rob Colorina, AIAC Investment Group.
You mentioned some time on the road.
I was curious as to how you manage your travel,
what you’re thinking about outside some
of the major cities and into the rural or
sort of the SME kind of territories.
MR.
PAI: Great question.
Thanks for asking.
I love traveling throughout those parts of
the country that one typically would not go
as a tourist.
During that same trip, for instance, I stopped
in Zelienople, Pennsylvania, population I
think 3,812.
Believe it or not, Zelienople is sort of the
hub in terms of internet access for a big
territory in western Pennsylvania.
And it was really useful for me to be able
to see that cable headend to understand how
that headend was trying to deliver internet
access to hilly parts of Western PA and to
see the business and economic challenges and
technical challenges that were involved in
internet access.
And, to be honest, those are the trips that
resonate the most with me.
You’re traveling to Dillard, Nebraska, and
getting to meet Chad and Courtney Lautman,
who’ve used the internet to build a beef
jerky distribution company that is shipping
nationwide.
It’s incredible.
Going to Fort Yukon, Alaska, and getting to
see how a teacher is able to connect with
her students, most of whom are Alaska natives,
in ways that were unthinkable a generation
ago.
Visiting Carthage, Mississippi, and looking
at a gigabit fiber deployment that was never
considered possible during the analogue age.
Even going back to my hometown of Parsons,
Kansas, and seeing some of the challenges
there.
My own high school, for instance, either didn’t
apply for E-Rate funding or didn’t get the
funding that they needed in order to get better
digital services.
And that sort of brought home to me at least
the fact that my own successors at Parsons
High School weren’t necessarily getting
the same opportunity as some of their brethren
in bigger places.
And so those are the visits that are real
important to me.
I grew up in a small town.
I grew up in rural America.
However long I may have lived in the big city,
I’m still a small town American at heart,
and I’m keenly aware that the digital divide
wrecks the greatest inequality when it comes
to smaller towns.
And so going forward I’m going to continue
doing those visits because it helps me keep
me grounded and it helps keep my eyes on the
prize here, which is that ubiquitous internet
access that every American who wants it is
able to get it is ultimately something that’s
going to make our nation much better off.
I’d also point out, by the way, that when
I’ve had a chance to talk to my international
counterparts, interestingly, this is the number-one
priority that they talk about as well.
I met my counterpart in Nigeria, for example,
in February, and I was struck by the fact
that he told me that 40 percent of Nigerians
lack internet access at all.
And those are extremely poor rural villages
in particular.
A couple of years ago, when I went to India,
I sat on the outskirts of a small village
in Bangalore, and I saw that internet access
for poor women was extremely important, especially
over the mobile phones, because that allowed
them to get and transmit money, which allowed
them to start their own businesses.
In Colombia, I met some small startup entrepreneurs
from rural areas that were developing apps
that allowed, for instance, fishermen to be
able to better communicate in order to assess
where the fish were and try to figure out
where the marketplace opportunity was.
And so this is not an American phenomenon.
And the other point I’ll just stress in
closing is that when I met recently with Senator
Angus King, outside of his office, he has
a wonderful poster of JFK with a quote on
it.
And it says, “Let us not search for the
Republican answer.
Let us not search for the Democratic answer.
Let us search for the right answer.”
And notwithstanding the political vicissitudes
of the Open Internet Order or the other things
that occupy the headlines, at the end of the
day, I remain optimistic, perhaps foolishly
so, that internet access is something we can
all rally around, that all of us are better
off as Americans when we focus on that prize.
And rural America, at least to me, is squarely
in the heart of that prize.
MR.
EISENACH: Other questions.
I see one in the back of the room here.
Q: Steven Nyikos.
I’m with the Carnegie Endowment next door.
MR.
PAI: Hi.
Q: I’m wondering — one of the greatest
ways to foster low-cost and efficient internet
access in new areas is going to be through
fostering competition.
Can you talk about measures that you might
— the FCC might be engaged in to foster
ISP competition specifically?
And with the light touch that you’re talking
about from the Clinton era, means of modernizing
and ensuring that that is an equal playing
field for startup or smaller ISPs and the
larger ISP companies.
MR.
PAI: Fantastic question.
So here we’ve been extremely aggressive.
As you heard during the speech, for instance
— also we have two basic tools in the toolbox.
One is the wise stewardship of the federal
subsidy programs that the FCC oversees.
And the other is the regulatory framework,
the rules of the road that we set for the
private sector.
So with respect to federal subsidies, the
bottom-line philosophy that I’ve tried to
apply to these programs, which I’m glad
my colleagues have supported, is making sure
that we redirect funding to the areas that
are unserved, to Americans who are off the
grid altogether, and make sure they are devoted
to carriers who are committed and have been
proven to be committed to developing broadband
networks in those areas.
And these are not the big companies by definition
because you don’t see as big of a return
on the investment in these areas.
These are some of the smaller companies that
are taking these funds and in a fiscally responsible
way applying them to close that digital divide.
Additionally, we’ve also taken a number
of other universal service actions along those
lines.
Just last month, for instance, at our meeting,
we took a very arcane step, which I mentioned
briefly, to change our CAPEX rules, which
inadvertently stood in the way of companies
wanting to deliver high-speed access to some
of the highest-cost areas within their territory.
And that was perversely a way of essentially
redlining off entire rural areas from broadband
deployment.
So the second major way we want to incentivize
competition is through adjusting our rules.
And here I’m really excited in particular
about the impact of small wireless and wired
broadband competitors.
On the wireless side, for instance, I’ve
consistently said that one of the reasons
I believe so much in five gigahertz spectrum
is that could be used by fixed wireless providers
to be a competitive alternative to their wired
brethren.
And so if we were able, for instance, to get
five gigahertz spectrum that involves very
wide channels, then they can supply very high
speeds to competitors.
It would be essentially comparable, hopefully,
to the fixed broadband networks.
And especially if we don’t need to deploy
all of that fixed infrastructure that you
would on the wired side.
That could be a pretty important competitors,
especially in rural areas.
With respect to the wired competitors too,
we’ve made sure that we take steps to relieve
some of the regulatory burdens, to make it
easier for them to build a business case so
they can compete with the big guys.
So, for example, the creation of the Broadband
Deployment Advisory Committee, the BDAC — they’re
targeting ways to make it easier for the smaller
competitors to gain access to poles, to make
is cheaper for them to attach equipment to
poles, for them to be able to get access to
the conduit that’s in the ground, or for
them to get quicker state and local approval
for some of these deployments.
If you think about it, these regulatory barriers,
they affect everybody who wants to be an ISP,
but especially the smaller competitors.
And just to give you one quick example of
that.
I visited with a company called Rocket Fiber,
small ISP, a startup ISP in Detroit, Michigan.
And they told me, when they’ve initially
tried to go to the city of Detroit to get
access to the city-owned poles, Detroit quoted
them a price of something like I want to say
$3,000, maybe even $5,000 for each and every
poll.
And if you’re a small ISP, I mean, come
on, in a city as densely populated as Detroit,
that price is prohibitive.
But negotiating down the price, they were
able to get access at a reasonable cost to
them.
And not every ISP is so lucky.
And so we want to reduce that cost element
in order to help those smaller competitors.
And moving forward, last September, I proposed
my digital empowerment agenda.
One critical part of that was for Congress
to give the FCC additional authority in this
area — help us create, for example, gigabit
opportunity zones, which would allow us to
designate either large rural counties or even
small urban areas as 75 percent or less of
the national median income.
And in those areas, we provide tax incentives
to these small companies to provide a competitive
alternative.
I’m thrilled to see Senator Capito recently
introduce legislation just this week on that
very score.
Similarly, we would love for Congress to consider
giving us additional authority over utility
poles that are — or poles that are owned
by governments and railroads.
Very arcane, it’s never going to make the
front page of any newspaper, but given the
fact that this is a major cost element for
smaller competitive ISPs that could really
help us attack that competition equation in
a way that will be good for consumers in the
long run.
MR.
EISENACH: Should we go here?
One on this side?
Go ahead.
Q: Hi.
Bill Signer with the Carmen Group.
MR.
PAI: Hi.
Q: First, thank you for coming and speaking
today.
Your comments are personal about the robocalls.
Whatever you do about that is great because
I got one while we were sitting here.
(Laughter.)
MR.
PAI: I hope you didn’t pay up.
Q: I did not, but I will tell you that one
of my thoughts about that is you should be
going after the people who benefit — not
the companies that are doing the calls, but
the end of beneficiaries of that so you could
be fining them and I think that would be great.
What I want to talk a little bit about is
I work with the burglar and fire alarm industry.
MR.
PAI: OK.
Q: Very highly competitive industry, overwhelmingly
small business and involved in public safety.
We’re concerned that the common carriers,
when they become competitors of ours, that
basically they use that control over the network
to get a competitive advantage.
You may be aware there are provisions in the
law that protect us.
We are concerned that — and this is not
a net neutrality issue.
What we’re concerned about is if things
in Title Two, which is where we are, go over
to the Federal Trade Commission, by the time
we get heard, a lot of our small businesses
are going to be put out of business.
So the two things we would like to see happen
is, one, continuation under FCC jurisdiction
for at least the alarm complaints and issues,
and, two, making sure — well, that’s basically
the major thing we’re concerned about.
MR.
PAI: OK.
Thanks for flagging that concern.
It’s been a while since I took a look at
the legal framework surrounding these issues,
but I’d be happy consider it.
In the meantime, please do file either in
an existing proceeding or if there is a petition
or application —
Q: The second part of it is because it only
applies basically to landlines, we want to
be modernized, and I’m sure it applies to
the internet service providers.
MR.
PAI: OK.
Like I said, I’d be happy to take a look.
Send some paper our way, and I’ll do my
best to carve out some time to take a look
at it.
MR.
EISENACH: I think we have time for one more
question probably.
We’ve had the left.
It’s time for the right.
Right, left.
I got one right back here.
Yes, sir.
Q: David Hatch with dealReporter.
So the previous FCC did not look favorably
at reducing the number of nationwide wireless
carriers from four to three.
And given the statements that you just made
about the level of competition, is that a
possibility that you’d be open to?
MR.
PAI: I take the role of the — my approach
to the regulatory role is one of humility
— that I don’t claim to know in a vacuum
what the optimal market structure of any particular
marketplace is, what the right number of competitors
should be.
Our goal is always to make sure that the marketplace
functions in a way that benefits the public
interest.
And so to me at least, we take a look at the
marketplace as it stands, try to figure out
is there competition, are prices going down,
is application and service innovation going
up, those kinds of things, and then make the
appropriate judgment.
For instance, through our wireless competition
report — if any transaction is presented
to us, the framework I’ve applied and I’ve
consistently applied going back to my statements
on November 30, 2011, when I was a nominee,
was that we always evaluate transactions based
on the public interest standard.
Figuring out whether the consummation of that
transaction would be good for competition
or consumers and to make the appropriate judgment
thereafter.
That’s the framework I’m going to apply
going forward if we’re presented with any
transaction where (it is ?).
MR.
EISENACH: I’m told we’ll take one more.
And I saw one more hand over here.
One more here.
Yes.
Here we go.
MR.
PAI: Behind the fellow with the stylish fedora.
Q: Yeah.
Marne Bax (ph) with “Morning Consult.”
I was just wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about — I don’t know if this
is related to the federal subsidy you were
talking about earlier, but Commissioner Clyburn
had suggested that the way that the universal
service fee is funded right now is unsustainable
since it’s coming mostly from landline phones.
Can you just talk a little bit about that
and how federal subsidies will be collected
in the future if there are changes to that.
MR.
PAI: Sure.
So to the folks who are blissfully unfamiliar
with this area, the universal service fund
is funded by essentially a tax that is on
every phone bill the consumer pays.
And so if you look at your bill, you see universal
service fee, those fees go into essentially
a pot of money that the FCC oversees.
There are four different universal service
and programs, one of which I mentioned today:
the high-cost program for delivering broadband
to rural American, an unserved America.
So, yeah, that fee is something that varies
over time.
The FCC and the company that oversees for
administering this program make a determination
about what that contribution factor is or
should be.
And there are existing bodies to determine,
you know, whether the fee should be adjusted.
Right now, my colleague Commissioner O’Rielly
is the chair of what’s called a joint board
that oversees these issues.
And they’re squarely tackling that question.
So we haven’t — the discussion has been
ongoing for quite a while, and we haven’t
made any determinations yet.
So I hate to pass the buck to my good friend,
but since he’s the chairman of that relevant
joint board, I have to defer answering — you’re
free to talk to him if you like about that
question.
MR.
EISENACH: Process reform in action.
PAI: I know.
I feel bad imposing homework on my colleagues.
MR.
EISENACH: Ajit, it’s been wonderful having
you here.
You learn something every time — I always
learn something when I listen to you.
Today I learned something I didn’t expect
that you’d spent so much time in prison.
(Laughter.)
So it’s — it’s not on your CV, but thanks
for letting us know.
MR.
PAI: Voluntarily I hasten to add, for those
watching at home.
Yeah.
MR.
EISENACH: Listen, thank you so much for being
here.
I ask everyone to join me in thanking Ajit.
Also stay seated as we’re leaving the room.
(Applause.)